five years old you can't even swim
without floaties and you want to
lock off yeah yeah no i mean the parents
i'm not talking to the five-year-old
kids because you can't even use these
words
question of the day where do you where's
the line between being a child performer
and being the victim of child abuse let
me explain the context
before we get to this vice video we're
going to rebuttal uh i want to be very
clear
because our recent not recent
three-year-old video on stephanie the 56
year old trans father
you're only recently was removed from
youtube for apparently
wow uh making their own apparently the
entire
56 year old trans five-year-old
community was stunned that we were not
supporters of them
wow uh i think transitioning
children is child abuse right you let me
know what you think
change my mind maybe we could do it
change your mind but i would probably be
acid milkshake uh of course activists
right now the transgender activism what
you see advice
um they claim that the wright hates
science this is something we hear a lot
i i i cannot fathom that argument when
you see
these kinds of videos advice when you
see the kind of anti-scientific rhetoric
uh really that's being substituted with
an agenda so here you go vice up this
documentary look at how parents
should know when to have their children
transition to the opposite gender
as families try to support their
children and lessen the potential for
self-harm
they're now forced to weigh the options
of early medical intervention
now kids like eight-year-old max o'brien
can delay the onset of puberty
using drugs called hormone walkers max
goes to boston children's hospital
which opened the first clinic for
transgender youth in the u.s
since 2007 i wouldn't let that
in the past couple years our volume has
just about doubled well i saw a white
lab coat in there
color me convinced it's also by the way
before we get to the substance i don't
know this is that
do you find it weird that they say uh a
drug known as hormone blockers like that
is the colloquialism but that's like a
drug known as clomiphene citrate it's
like
a drug known as a painkiller
a drug that is a chemical which does
something medically why would they say
it's
a hormone blocker you don't need to say
a drug known as hormone blocker no you
just see it's hormonal so
this is what vice does they have these
interviews with these experts right
people who write lab coats um but they
don't tell you that these trans activist
doctors
actively perpetuate anti-scientific
myths about transgenders and they
completely ignore huge amounts
of evidence that contradict their dogma
and something else they're talking about
uh
young children yeah here's something i
want to genuinely know because
weighing their options because of how
their children feel some of these kids
are eight-year-olds
yeah we don't allow eight-year-olds to
make decisions about anything
specifically sex right you don't allow
an eight-year-old cannot consider rules
you don't allow them to make any sexual
decisions yet you are allowing them to
make decisions
that will permanently alter their sexual
functioning
and their social sex life for the rest
of their life yeah
in what other scenario can you imagine
us do this is the only scenario we allow
eight-year-olds to make
permanent life-altering sexual decisions
yeah and i think it's important to know
in this video they spend about the first
five to eight minutes
uh telling you family stories really
trying to soften you up to situations
and they start off with
a five-year-old yeah they start off with
somebody who was maybe looking at
transitioning
at three and four years old like and
this entire thing is meant to think
that this is such a hard life that we
have to do this so they're trying to set
you up for an emotional training not
five years old you can't even swim
without floaties and you want to lock
off
your dick yeah no that's i mean the
parents i'm not talking to the
five-year-old kids because you can't
even use these words
how can you even describe the naughty
word procedure you can't use
without putting a nickel in a swear jar
okay next clip
another one is really kind of the
psychosocial development our brains are
supposed to be
you know exposed to estrogen and
testosterone
you know if you're not getting your sex
steroids do you still go through that
and how important is that
in gender identification we don't know
uh no actually we do know
okay so they're talking about giving
hormone blockers to kids right right
giving them
uh hormone blockers seems to lock them
into a permanent condition of gender
dysphoria
this is something people don't talk
about and it's important we'll come back
to it if the kids don't transition early
on about 75 to 90 percent of the kids
completely grow out of it but if you
look at those who undergo the puberty
blockers
drugs commonly known as hormone blockers
what are they uncommonly known as you
wouldn't be able to pronounce it well
just say hormone blocker
if you look at the kids who undergo
hormone blockers the number drops from
75 to 90 percent you grow out of it two
zero okay
that's incredible so let's get to some
other some some of the other myths that
you see in this
video um they try to also tell you that
puberty blockers hormone blockers are
reversible
if max changes his mind at any point we
can
release the blockade and we know from
lots of things cuba star wars into
puberty on his own
a female puberty to me blockers is again
it's not a permanent thing
it just puts a pause for a while no it
is much more severe than putting the
cause
is it nice you could just say just puts
a pause a pause to what
a positive fusing of growth plates and
proper hormonal development as long as
facial structure ligaments overall
connective tissue he really could be
walking around like he has rickets we
don't know
it can permanent hormone blockers can
permanently affect height okay girls can
have a male growth spurt guys can end up
with a female stature
okay yeah these are not things that you
can correct do you remember by the way
what we're talking about this you're as
a kid when these to tell you don't drink
coffee it might stunt your growth
yeah they just say don't or no lifting
weights or like don't lift away it's too
young don't
don't drink coffee like oh i might i
might shave off an inch and a half but
now we're trying
to do it pumping their their bodies full
of estrogen
or foreign hormones but it is remarkable
to me that they say they act as though
ah this is just very mild you know we
can just put you on hormone altering
puberty blockers and if you don't like
it you can go back
well hold on a second first do no harm
right you've heard of that with doctors
how about we don't put them on hormone
blockers and see if they figure it out
especially when 75 to 90 of them
don't end up being having gender
dysmorphia for the rest of their life
anyway
and by the way while we're talking about
hormone blockers
it's important to note that even having
naturally low levels of a lot of these
hormones can damage the human body
right so low testosterone in men linked
to diabetes heart problems obesity
uh other hormones particularly women
estrogen can they help
contribute to mental well-being low
levels strongly correlated with
increased suicide attempts
this is something to think about we
already have a certain demographic here
transgenders with an insanely high
suicide rate do we really want to start
to severely alter hormones which
directly correlate to one's mental state
yeah at a younger age by the way hit the
notification bell we're talking about
mental state because subscriptions don't
mean a whole lot anymore
join up at mudclub lighthouse credit.com
club unless you just want vice to win
and uh subscribe on itunes okay another
thing to tell you know the kids won't be
able to be themselves if you don't let
them transfer
someone think of the children
transgender children we're trying to do
is provide the treatment the care um
for young people who in the afternoon
are just very scared
i can't tell have a very high likelihood
of taking their lives
so my sense is cross-sex hormones
pubertal blockers
are absolutely medically necessary
that's your feeling only it's wrong
it is not true does that pass as a
medical opinion
well you know here's the thing they
don't talk about people under with
gender dysphoria who undergo
surgery they're still 19 times more
likely to commit suicide than the
general population you cannot
find that kind of a demographic anywhere
outside of
okay from what i understand paranoid
schizophrenics you don't even find it in
the demographics of american slaves or
holocaust
survivors wow yeah that's that's what
we're supposed to believe because they
couldn't take a dump at the preferred
bathroom at a denny's
but that's why you find them hanging
from a noose in the basement listen it's
not that people have no compassion right
we're just talking about the science and
we're looking at the actual solutions to
the problem
which just in the opinion of most people
here is not pumping a five-year-old full
of
drugs known as hormone blockers
[Laughter]
all right the next thing is
transitioning they want to make you
think that it's the only option
people talk about as being such brave
and courageous parents and stuff i just
i didn't see any other options the vice
interviewer said that right
to me he i don't think he would have
made it i mean the stuff that he's
said and felt and so i want a live kid i
want my kid
i don't care i'll take him as a boy it
doesn't matter to me you know i don't
know people just say i'm a
brave courageous parent i don't i don't
consider myself a hero
just because i gave my kids some
anastrozole or clomiphene citrate
i don't know i don't think i deserve a
metal pinned on this jacket i do have a
few here that i uh
got from the vice interviewer with the
uh angry lesbian haircut
um
[Laughter]
none of this is none of this is true we
feel like we would have lost it now talk
about a five year old how many five year
olds are committing suicide five year
olds don't talk like this
they don't no they don't in the video
was a five-year-old goes i
am happier now i'm more fulfilled
because i am comfortable in my own skin
yeah
what are you wendy williams they're
still going to be 19 times more likely
to exist in the general population i
mean if they go through
with the transition right yeah now if
you get them therapy
even without therapy but specifically
with therapy the numbers get better 75
to 90
of those kids will grow out of it right
so any way you look at it
75 to 90 will grow out of that 19 times
the general population suicide rate so
if you want to be a good parent say i
think i may have
you know my six-year-old was looking up
old old derby single safety razor blades
and i said why are you adding that to
amazon cart what five six-year-olds is
killing themselves
right yeah that's an actual brand of
okay
by the way that's what uh michael keaton
was using in pacific heights but
so i would say if you as a parent if you
put those two stats next to each other
you can have 19 times the suicide rate
or 75 to 90 percent chance that things
are going to get better right
regardless it's easy whether you dvr we
call it a drag race or not
yeah this isn't a hard question this is
the only option it's like it's like
overweight people who go straight
to getting lap bands like well hold on
did you exercise did you diet did you go
to the nutrition ah
stomach table now how about you just
revoke your trader joe's snack aisle
card i don't know if they sell cards
specifically for straight but
it is probably they are not as healthy
as you would think they are
definitely not as healthy but it does
seem to be the wrong way out of the
solution also completely related but 40
of those patients are overweight again
in five years oh which again would
correlate to this idea of the quick out
that these kids are
not going to have they're not going to
be plagued by by mental disorders for
the rest
if you don't solve the mental issues
here okay
you don't solve the likelihood of a
suicide rate that's the truth if you're
talking about helping these children
putting them into uh anyway let's let's
go on to the next next
there is no next question there's too
much 28 minute videos
i wish there were more there we went to
the transgender town hall that one time
remember
it was banned from youtube with dr rex's
butt
they were unfortunate they were coaching
us and how to put our kids down hormone
replacement therapy
yeah it's really scary when you have you
have doctors you have entire medical
practices
who are they're practicing this on
gender theory not science
right and a lot of the reason for this
that you're seeing this there's
there's a big reason to play the left
wants to criminalize everyone who
doesn't recognize this here doctors
pastors coaches you look at some of the
bills that have been proposed right if
you don't use the pr
we already see it in canada if you don't
use the proper pronouns it's not only
proper pronouns i should say if you
don't use the pronouns that someone
determines on a day-to-day basis and it
changes on any given day
they want that to be criminalized it's
even scarier when you think that these
people
who want they also believe that
healthcare is a human right yeah so it
just shows you there's no limit to what
they'll demand it's not about
catastrophic
care it's not about basic it's not even
about birth control
it's not even about providing 16 out of
21 birth controls that you see with
hobby lobby so they show up and they
protest and they have sandra fluke
it's about all the way up to drugs known
as hormone blockers for seven-year-old
kids
and they believe this should be
subsidized by the taxpayers who by the
way can have no
say in helping children transition to
the opposite gender
and one thing i hear a lot i hear a lot
of people say like this isn't really a
big deal you know the the free speech
stuff the kids on campus the gender st
the cultural war stuff
let's just talk it's the economy stupid
but we are literally talking
about completely eliminating the entire
concept of gender by extension the
family the nuclear family the central
building block for the
for all of western civilization's way of
life this is probably the most important
issue that we're facing today
saying that men and women are of no
intrinsic value
are not unique and are fundamentally
interchangeable from as early as
five years old it will make us worse
husbands it will make us worse fathers
it will make us worse mothers it will
make us
worse parents overall and it'll make us
a weaker people by the way
this is all done predicated on the idea
that doing this
is compassionate well you know what you
are putting these people
into an estrogen injected shallow grave
and i hope you feel good about
i hope your white guilt is worth it if
you like this video this is the part
where i would usually tell you to
subscribe but
i can't do it anymore i'm going to tell
you to subscribe and then youtube is
going to decide that
we can't reach you even though you
subscribe to this channel and then i'll
say hit the notification bell
and then the notification bell won't
even be there anymore
i don't know what to say more than
likely you'll find my face in a milk
carton but do what you can to stop it
it's just it's just it probably won't do
much